six
seven
and eight I'm happy to close in the
chair I'm looking for a second there
thank you very much kid
all those in favor
against
and abstentions okay
thank you Ruth
action list item number three with their
no outstanding actions so we move on to
the Declarations of Interest
members with interest should refer to
the agenda item describe the nature of
their interest when the item is
considered
agreement of gender items part one and
two
we do have a part two this afternoon so
we just take a vote on that I'm happy to
propose in the chairs seconded thank you
Claire all those in favor
that's unanimous
item number six
urgent matters brought forward with the
permission of the chair and I don't have
any items
no items so we're on to item seven audit
reports issued Pages 9 to 14 to receive
a report from the Devon audit
partnership
so
yes so
I have questions
so
um I'm following three reports for you
to review today
um the first one relates to non-domestic
rates so as you can see we've concluded
that good controls are in place
including over the application of
discounts and reliefs
um and and those were raised timely in
terms of collection
um the um there's been Improvement in
the collection rate to 98.8 for 2021-22
so um that's that's good
um I suppose the main main point we're
making
um is that there's been unfortunately A
reduced attention to chasing of debtors
in this area
um and just just to clarify so it does
take 320
000 pounds
um over that is over 12 years of course
so that's sort of year on year so
um and the two medium recommendations we
make relate to actively looking at the
the older debts and introducing the use
of enforcement agents to direct to
collect the debt that's possible for the
council and then the second one to to
write off I suppose the larger debts
um overall I suppose for the level of
right offices is quite quite low so a
bit more sort of focus on like writing
of debt that's not recoverable certainly
going back over the years
reports on on risk management again we
looked at the council's arrangements to
manage risk and so on
um just so overall I thought the uh the
the corporate risks that you've um
you've you've got are reasonable to us
and refactor challenges that the council
faces
um we think there's good conversations
by senior health managers in its
meetings and so on to discuss risk
um and obviously there's that Focus for
instance on The Current financial risks
um that their Council faces and so on
um we do note the need for the risk
management Forum to meet more more
regularly that's obviously a key key
form to enable you to sort of identify
and escalate and conserve a
cross-cutting risks and so on
um and also
we also suggested that
um while service areas identify and have
risk versus the beginning of the year we
sort of thought well it's probably used
for for a midpoint review so that a
service looks at its wrist and say okay
are they still current or what other
other risks that might might exist and
so on
um so that that we thought that for
useful
um so and then finally housing options
so
um there's a request that
um Council Office has asked us to to
look at which I probably shows that
they're aware of that of the issue and
so on
um as as you can see the significant
expenditure compared to the actual
budget
um
so I suppose a good point is that
overall we can see that the council is
placing homeless people in quotes with
legislation and the policy and so on
um then there's a as you know there's a
homeless strategy
but um it's not being I suppose reviewed
very recently
um and the action plan was not up to
date um when we looked at it
um so to part of our work
um as you may notice in in report
um as included sort of comparing
um what this Council does to have our
councils
um and I suppose this is what we'd
expect
um officers also to do in terms of
thinking well what what is it that are
the neighboring councils and others do
to try to mitigate that's the financial
another risk
um what we also
um I suppose lip type of functioning of
the team and the processes and systems
and so on
um so we also concluded that there could
be more effective
um in in their systems and processes
they could be more effective in for
instance processing housing benefit
forms
they use spreadsheets quite a lot rather
than having a sort of end-to-end system
to manage for the transactions and so on
um but um you'll be aware that the
council has has formed a sort of project
team to to look at I suppose our
recommendations about just the wider
piece so that that's how it was left in
verse of in recommendations but as I
said well there's a rather piece of work
undergoing and I think you're due to
discuss that um later in this meeting
so um that's also proof summary so I'm
happy to take any any questions
thank you very much indeed Paul for some
very in-depth reports there
um I'm going through it open to the
floor would anybody like to ask any
questions
[Music]
with getting the benefits is that
impacting on the clients the customers
what have you like to call them or is
that just us getting our money back
from central government
the housing benefits
no it doesn't and it doesn't affect the
clients because their Combs will always
be backdated the predominant problem
that it's caused is having a knock-on
effect on the webs and Ben's team
because we've had some delays within
that team so not having the information
in as it should be is then causing
double sometimes triple handling because
the revs and bends have to go back to
the housing team and the housing team
then having to redo the information and
send it back and there are reasons and
and I'll talk for a bit more when I'm
talking about the housing action plan as
well if that helps but it doesn't affect
payments in their their claims
okay I think you have a question to come
in
okay I'm sorry
um
yeah it just is it is it appropriate to
talk about the the housing option report
now or is that coming into part two
that's going to come in part to a pool
if you're able to stay for that part two
item I think it'll be
very affirmative to get some detail
behind but I think if we park that yeah
and then we can go right through
and take that then there's much to
discuss
okay thank you so no further questions
on
raw items also if we
note item seven then if you're happy
with that I'll move on to item eight
which is counter fraud and resilience
assessment report Pages 15 to 24. so
again back to the northern partnership
and welcome to the meeting
thank you very much my name is Ken
Johnson I'm from Dublin water
partnership on the counterfield services
manager for the organization
what we tried to do now press your
button please thank you again
is it online
um sorry I'll start again um so my name
is Ken Johnson I'm from the Devon water
partnership we
on the accountable services manager and
as we've um you you're part of the devil
order partnership we're now trying to
involve is more more and more to involve
the account for all side of things as
well as the audit team
um and try and get some risk assessments
set up
um Paul has normally been helping create
this document with the fraud resilience
obviously my expertise is informed I've
been working in counter fraud and local
government for about 15 years
um
the many many prosecutions policies
whatever your name you know we were
involved on a sort of national level
with with a lot of the
um government organizations representing
fraud to create standards in fraud and
fraud investigation across the public
sector
so we wanted to give a report on where
we think um college is and as you can
see from the report you tip most of the
boxes that are required by the set for
guidelines
um you're not alone in in many respects
we need to look a stronger look at the
risk assessment side of things to make
sure that we understand where those
risks are I mean I could go through a
list as long as you're on where we're
looking at potential offenses across
other councils what we need to do is
recognize it record it as potential
fraud and record the outcomes and you'll
see from sort of right at the end of the
report right at the end of the the
assessment it's one of the things that
we need to start publishing uh would
need to start publishing what it's
actually spending and what it actually
does about fraud and that's part of the
transparency criteria
I say You're Not Alone
um I'm trying to play with this across
Devon you're one of a few local
authorities I'm trying to get this off
the ground with but the main message
from the report and I I can go through
it in detail if you want um
but the main message from the report is
you are doing well but I would like to
sort of really get in and understand the
risks that you're facing especially at
this time in the economy there are
savings to be made through kind of fraud
work
um
I say if you've had a read of it I'm
happy to answer any questions I don't
want to sort of
dragging all the way through unless you
really want to go through it that's fine
will it be possible just to give us an
example of something we could be doing
better just for the members present okay
because I can look in one of the ones
there you've got say council tax a
single person discount okay I know of it
I'm sure you could do experience stuff
and you probably could find quite a few
um examples of where people aren't
actually living in a property on their
own and getting a discount on
unreasonably but by the same token I
also understand that the benefit that
has gone to somebody else at Devon
County Council in Maine and the costs
for the Council of doing the exercise
yep
get it
the majority of the the loan share of
the money goes to and goes to the County
Council
um there is something in training at the
moment um
a broker a situation where Devon are are
happy to fund and exercise
a fully managed exercise to look at
single person discount reviews across
the piece so it's not just storage it'll
be all the districts
um
what that will enable us to do is
actually go back to a set date and that
can be agreed the details to be agreed
and I understand that if you were to run
a single person discount review
hey you've got to fund it and then B
you've got to Source the replies that
come back that's why we're trying to
look at
um
Brooklyn idea where a third agent is
actually able to come in take your data
do the matches that they require contact
everybody that needs to be contacted
fully manage the service and then put it
back in your systems
they're estimating that that's
potentially 1.4 million across Devon in
cancer tax uplift so that would be a
significant thing and that's why Dave
and I look into
happy to inject that sort of amount of
money to to get that return okay so you
would be looking at potentially I say
although it's not the place for the
exact detail because we don't have it
yet but looking at the cost of about 100
Grand you would be looking for a 1.4
million return on that so
an uplifting council tax
okay so that sort of thing
um your housing not seems to be um a
topic at the moment obviously we're
highly involved with
um social housing fraud um
investigations across Devon
um you're all part of the Devon options
um
Devon Holmes Choice options based
organization so
we're already working with them what we
found is we can get in at the ground
floor and actually change some of those
um where people are making applications
and very often they might be mistaken
false but sometimes they are
deliberately fraud and in those those
instances we are able to
change the tone if you like about people
who are entitled to housing absolutely
must be on the register those who
shouldn't be on the register shouldn't
be on the register
so there are things we can do around
that as well so
you can you can basically throw it throw
a stone in any Council service and you
will find something and they say we are
looking at other areas
um you say council tax you could look at
non-domestic rates you can look at
anything that the council deals with
basically and we will come up with
something and it's about that's
generating that risk register is about
getting the managers to staff and us to
be able to understand where those
potential risks are
then we can actually say what are you
actually doing many of your departments
will have
contingencies in place for kind of kind
of fraud work you know there'll be
separation the duties there will be
um you know reporting lines that will be
all sorts of things that are actually in
place but at the moment there's no way
of you have an audit but there's no way
of centralized recording what is going
on with you helping to stop in fraud so
and the other thing would be to make
someone training available to to
councilors all the way down through to
Frontline staff
um just so that we all understand
just how big the problem is and where
we're losing money and what we can do
about it
could just ask about that social housing
threat so is this the social where
somebody saw blacks I was this somebody
actually getting social housing who is
lying about their criteria and getting
social housing when they would not
otherwise we deal with both we so
historically dealt with both when they
when they entered the down homes
register down on the shores register
very often we're able to take much
information and it suddenly comes up
that actually they don't live there they
live over there they're not homeless or
Etc et cetera people do make false
statements on their applications and
that's a section two offense
the big stopping at getting into the
stopping for getting into the system is
much more valuable than trying to weed
it out once it's already in there so for
us the Devon Homes Choice team would be
a real
point of of concentration and that they
could
if they knew where to report it we can
contact that person and it's not a case
of if the fraud team get involved you're
guilty as if the fraud didn't get
involved I hope you're telling the truth
and we can we can we can dig into that
and we've got a lot more avenues for
making sure that the facts that they say
on a form are actually what is is the
truth
um the other side of it is we get quite
right with the subletting
it's I've just literally got a house
back for a Housing Association
and it's been
I was 2003 so it's been sublet for that
long
and when you think about the number of
people that could have probably been in
and out of that three bedroom property
and how much that's costing a local
authority to emergency accommodate
somebody that's where we it's a huge
saving that you can make there
does anybody have any questions
I don't have any questions chair but
that's the issue about training I think
has been mentioned twice already
nobody ever complains they can't do
anything else
in the council
um we've heard Tony mentioned by both of
you and the requirements for that now I
know when I first became a counselor I
thought you were familiar I sat through
your training on Exeter with our chair
um and I found it really useful I've
gotten a real Panic about sort of
company credit cards and uh things and
sort of interrogated I don't think it
was David then I think it was Steve
Harris about the use of those in our
organization and what so fast they were
um we are going to be facing elections
in May so we may well have a cohort of
new councilors
so I think if we're planning this as
part of our favorite program we want to
uh
tackle that
as soon as really they become cancer
there's much in order and governance
training organized in the aftermath of
the next election
um
in conjunction with North Devon Council
I think that tends to be quite General
but I think these two areas are really
key and will probably lead a more
specific approach
especially any new members of this
committee to actually undertake that
training so I'd like to see that feature
when we come to our sort of forward plan
of actually making sure it's not just a
general order in governance training
because at times people are very um
should we say they aren't fired up with
enthusiasm to sit on audit and
governance and yet it is such an
important part of the role of the
council so we must try and beef it up as
to what an effective role it can be so
that's all the Home Choice register I
see where you're coming from that you
want to nip it in the buds registration
point because not only are you allowing
them to get into the system but you
artificially inflating the housing needs
side of things but I would have thought
the validation process
of validating
an applicant before then or at the point
of offer is one of the opportunities for
us to actually check those things out
you're absolutely right and I'm sure
that you don't know which Choice team
actually do and a lot of the referrals
that we receive from other organizations
are from the Debenhams Choice team where
um you know the team are actually
disputing whether the information that's
been provided is accurate and sometimes
when it is accurate that's absolutely
fine to say we don't have there's no
side to this it's a case of if it's if
it's genuine then it's genuine it's
absolutely fine but if it's not
sometimes just the inclusion of our
um our team is you know and asking
someone to come and have a chat is is
enough for them to sort of um
rethink their status yeah yeah
absolutely thank you
can I just ask do we have
a team that can investigate or are
investigating
issues where
this fraud is coming to light where
possibly people are claiming single
person discount
Stacy yep so we've we've got a visiting
officer that goes around and checks
properties
um
especially when it comes to knee builds
as well but it it's not an easy easy
thing but yeah we do have a visiting
officer within the council tax team
David just to add I mean
as information comes to light it's
passed to the relevant members of that
Reverend benefits or for a recently
we've been doing a lot of household
support
um claims crisis payments and then
sometimes through that process it comes
to like that actually people
aren't registered at that address
and maybe somebody's claiming a single
person discount that they shouldn't do
well like a stages we haven't
we're not we've done exercises in the
past where we get really Experian and
then type of organizations that those
credit traces of more than one adult at
home which will give you an indication
there was two adults or who are living
in a property so we've done that in the
past but it was a colleague from dap uh
referred to to have that on a more
Devon Rod is the most efficient way of
doing it because also that cuts all the
queries out down the line
for instances do come to light
actively the history of that property to
see
if we can reclaim monies from previous
years is that possible as well
I think on the last time we did an
exercise we were updated to the time but
how successful and Recovery I couldn't
answer at this juncture
okay thank you
all right so if there are no further
questions we will note
about that report
and we'll then move on to item nine
which is to receive a report from Grant
Thornton so Julia
um
councilors and policies in advance if I
appear to be sprinting at people's
sentences have come around just at the
right time
um so um our progress reports um in
front of you today gives you an update
on the current work that we are doing
for the authority and following on from
the the last order Committee in October
obviously the key aspect of the work
that we are looking to conclude is our
financial statements audit work now
based on the update we gave to the last
meeting that work was obviously
substantially progressed at that stage
and we spent some weeks in the right to
Christmas including that outstanding
work and so we're just at that stage now
we're just completing these sort of
final completion procedures
unfortunately we had a bit of sickness
prior to Christmas that
um hindered our ability to conclude that
just before Christmas but um we're very
committed to finalizing that work now in
January with the view of then starting
our planning 22 23 from from February
onwards we set out in the program also
updates on Valley for many so the value
for money 2021 report obviously was
reported to the to the last meeting and
we will sort of formally follow up
anything from that report as well as
looking at any new updates to the
arrangements over the coming weeks
obviously our priority at the moment is
to finish off the final financial
statements work but then we're looking
to finalize our vfm work in in in
February
and the remainder of the progress report
also gives you the sector update as well
at the back end of the report that just
gives you some updates on recent
Publications and latest Market
developments
um very happy uh chair to take any
particular questions
thank you very much do we have any
questions
for Grant Thornton
no questions for you today so thank you
very much indeed it's all running to
time and then
obviously we have um as as previously
reported this committee we have
obviously incurred some some challenges
uh and delays to to the work that we're
very committed to making sure that we
close this off in in January so
um there's obviously been a lot of
national updates very recently just
prior to Christmas around the accounting
for infrastructure which has held up a
number of local Authority audits so
certainly January the firm as a whole is
is very committed to to dealing with
those outstanding Legacy audits so
absolutely by the end of January we'll
be firmly back on track chair thank you
okay and one final question from me um
I've got very long in the tooth and I
want to make sure there are no hidden
charges coming forward for the council
can you confirm that is the case this
year
so so in terms of the 2021 audit we've
obviously reported fees for both 2021
and 21-22 and order I understand that
the the scale fees for 2023 have now
been fully communicated to the authority
through psaa which is
um I think they published those uh just
prior to Christmas so in light of those
have been reported there's nothing
additional that we need to highlight or
bring to your attention in terms of the
audit fees
music to my ears thank you very much
indeed thank you so we will note
um
your report
and move on to item 10 revision to
financial procedures pages 39 to 42 and
to receive a report from our section 151
officer so over to you David yeah thank
you chair
um I just approved report
we have Financial procedures and we've
you saw the last time they were revised
the financial procedures are probably
over about 200 pages of them
I'm probably Council Hudson was the one
councilor actually read all of them I
suspect
the small reports just some
suggested tweaks to the financial
procedures which I'm hoping to strike
the balance between giving a bit of
operational flexibility for the officers
but I was so maintained in the control
for the elected members
I'll go through them one by one and
hopefully at the end I'll be you will
recommend that they all go to full
Council for their approval are you may
not want to prove any of them or maybe
approve some of them so if I just go for
what I've done as a farmer is I've taken
the extract from the existing Financial
procedures and then I've given a
suggested wording
um the first one an underlying on a few
of these on almost all of them is
inflation these limits haven't been
raised since 2016 and I think actually
probably actually predates that for some
of them
so obviously over the course of time as
inflation
increases and particularly without quite
High inflation recently the value of
some of these limits becomes a little
less functional and operationally
efficient So currently where we want to
Tender for goods or services that's over
seven and a half thousand pounds we have
to go and get um free quotes and
suggestion that cuts raised to ten
thousand pounds
and the rationale of course is the
inflation now unfortunately it can be
quite time consuming to get free
qualitations
um
the next
um suggestion it says
um on stage two cool wording postal
franking machines must be securely held
an officer responsible keep proper
records of the usage and verify the
balances held in the machine as at the
31st of March each year
and our discussion working is that
essentially wording is that postal fund
communities must be securely held now
the reason for that is the value on the
Frankie machine
will not exceed the value that we accrue
for at the end of financial year so
put simply
we used to have a limit for doing Manual
accruals of two thousand pounds so if on
the Frankie machine there was two
thousand five hundred pounds of balance
we would make a year-end adjustment to
that essentially as a prep and we've
prepaid for postage we've put a balance
on that frankly machine we prepaid to
Postage and we would declare that as a
prepayment and essentially what we do is
we will reduce our expenditure on
postage for that year we've got a limit
of 5 000 pounds
now so we wouldn't be a balance on the
Frankie machine that would ever exceed
that
and the next suggested changes to
financial procedures to provide each
operational manager member sm2 with a
monthly budget report showing receipts
and payments against budget and
suggested version shall provide each
operational manager a member of sm2 of a
quarterly budget report showing receipts
and payments against budget
and the ration hours this actually
allows as well how we report we report
on a quarterly basis to internal
overview and scrutin and The Wider
Council membership
and in practice managers can request an
update on their budgets
at any time so that happens quite often
a project management just wants to know
where we are do some forecasting they
want to do a restructure see if they've
got enough money to get some agency
staff in that happens on an organic
basis so I'm just suggesting that we'd
only do
firmly commit to doing the most
monitoring those utility which is what
we do
and if you turn to page four
this is the one that I'd most likely to
approve but obviously it's for
colleagues here to decide
equivalent assets valued at over 10 000
pounds must be entered onto the
council's asset register
and the suggested version word in his
asset about over fifteen thousand must
be answered entered onto the council's
asset register
so for accountant purposes and this is
why our code at Grand Fountain were um
Auditors on at the appropriate time in
our procedures we say the capital is a
value of ten thousand it's only one item
with a life of one more than one year we
can combine bulk items that are less
than ten thousand pounds if they come to
over ten thousand such as purchasing a
book lot of ICT equipment
we actually have to have full Council
approval
to have all additions onto our Council
approved Capital program and the Cashel
limits haven't been made for seven years
continentality relatively minor piece of
equipment now following the capital
limit and capital expenditures account
for differently from day-to-day Revenue
it requires a creation of entry on the
council's asset register a depreciation
of the assets life and identify
identification of the funding for the
capital item so whenever we have
anything as capital it causes us more
works as a fundamental this came to
light for myself when Richard Hayes our
operations manager bought a second-hand
wood chipper at 10 850 pounds
and that kind of thought to myself that
probably this limit is is too low
because it's it's a very
I'd say an operational piece of
equipment
um well we certainly would last more
than a year but it was ideally that
would like not to have to always create
a capital asset just for anything that's
just over ten thousand pounds
um the recommendation is that the
members of this commit to recommend the
revisions
members of this committee recommend the
revision to full Council for approval
happy to take any questions
thank you
David closely together and I I apologize
that I haven't actually discussed this
with you beforehand
um
I understand your rationale for
6.1.7 about the monthly budgets being
reported importantly because it aligns
very well with the qbr
but we have some budgets that are
can run away with expenditure very very
quickly due to ill health agency staff
the housing crisis
and I think those at risk Services need
to have specifically at this time uh
more close monitoring do you want me to
ask both questions
so I'm happy for it on a general
principle but I think if Services have
been identified through audit reports as
being
needing attention then I think we should
treat them separately my second question
is with relate relating to assets over
the value of ten thousand pounds
raising the limit to 15. do we have to
then consider uh any other alterations
to our disposal of assets procedures as
to whether
because those have to be reported to
committee at the moment so how do we do
we need to update that part of our
processes as well and
um
I mean every three weeks now the housing
manager is coming in and giving us an
update on our expenditure on temporary
accommodation but also my accountant
Gideon
he is reporting that on a monthly basis
so well there's attention to we also do
internally within Finance we report on
the collection fund which is council tax
and business rates on a monthly basis
for our own benefits and where issues
arise a few years ago we had a big issue
with planning and actually getting not
been able to Resource the department and
get an agency Staffing
we would have an update on that over two
weeks on the agency spend that we had in
practice I think we spent the best part
of the third of a million pounds when
the year was out on agency's debt so
it's
I would be disappointed if any of the
officers MIT were bringing those sort of
things to light and actually having us
out of microscope on some of these
things as they arise
you know you'll know the work that we
did on the environment Center in the
Turing that we did so we do do that I
think wasting uh
cleansing section obviously because we
keep our service on the road and we are
heavily reliant on agency staff to fill
those gaps to keep our highly respected
service on and I haven't got a problem
with that but I just think we need to
make sure that batteries are getting out
of control Richard haste or Optimum is
one of our more needy customers of
finance and he gets monthly updates from
rent that's great thank you thank you
yeah
just just to add to that Council Hodge
service
um all appointments come to senior
management team on Monday
so no manager can just go in a point
agency without that going through that
approval process for that reason
um David I mean David's Finance so
everything with David is finance and
expenditure and it would expect him to
be focused on that
but as I'll come into my report shortly
because there are obviously other
factors included in that
thank you for those you know I know
you're on the ball and I I know
we actually work quite well together and
but the issue for us is we're recording
this as a change in policy and I wanted
to make sure that we were actually
saying but there are exceptions and that
that is noted
um that we are being uh prudent
I'll come back to you on the question
yet about the disposals no the disposal
is more just I didn't go to look at that
level because we disposed of assets and
a more infrequent basis and generally
the disposals largely would be old
Vehicles which have come to the end of
their useful Life In The Refuge
department so there's controls within
that in terms of going out to Arch and
Etc and I wasn't really intending to
change them and the lower disposal
pieces of land we've got to consult with
the ward members and I think that's
right that that should stay there so the
capital
um
once it's become a capital asset
is the Mechanics for writing out whether
Capital asset register are still the
same whether it's 20 pound or two
hundred thousand pounds so that doesn't
save any load for the team not having to
write a report to full Council to
put on our capital
approve capital program at an 11 000
pound wood chipper does save me time at
the officers so it was still on the
registers it's under the website but
it's not run the registered like this
laptop there's a laptop I'm talking
about this iPad and we have a serial
number and other internal mechanical
okay Julie you'd like to come in here
very much um
as just to ask a few questions I think
that it's already partially addressed
the first the first one I was just going
to clarify was
um more around the stewardship of of
assets recognizing it obviously won't
now be treated as capital but from a
security and stewardship of the assets
point of view presumably there's still
an inventory kept of all assets whether
it's
above 10 K or 15K or otherwise you can
still keep a list of what you've got and
know what's within authorities ownership
was the first question the second
question was more recognizing some of
the wider Financial challenges uh you
know the authorities is working through
could raise in this limit albeit it's
quite a small sort of inconsequential
increase could that inadvertently put
additional pressures on the council's
revenue budget
well they're still going to be monitored
on their performance so when and Richard
came with the wood chipper I'm still
reviewing our expansion The Wider aspect
of his budget essentially
um it really is just to get the
more modest expenditure and not have the
burden because
you think of the process how often we
meet at full Council to do a rapport to
put that on and all you've actually
essentially bought is a second hand wood
chipper
um now we had to do this when we brought
the ground maintenance contract in but
that was more substantial there was that
this is just a small Legacy from when we
brought the ground maintenance contracts
in and realized that we didn't actually
have a piece of equipment that would
really and then on this one as well we
were Outsourcing the work so this is
actually going to save us money it's
going to pay itself back within like
probably two years maybe not even that
probably less than that
I suppose just to scrutinize 677.
can I just ask you in your experience
what other councils do in this situation
just so we can compare and contrast
um
certainly you know it will vary from one
authority to another certainly the
larger authorities which are met with a
much bigger asset base you know I've
seen
um sort of levels and values of up to
about 25 30 000. so it there is some
variation from uh from authority to
Authority I've seen it as low as five so
it will come down to you know it is it
is for County determine its policy so
certainly you are with smack in the
middle of that range of experiences I've
certainly seen elsewhere so it doesn't
cause me any great concern of the
reasons and I understand the reasons for
the limit it's more just have have the
sort of broadness of considerations been
been thought of so certainly no concerns
from from my perspective I don't know if
internal to have a view
yeah
and from the internal audit point of
view I can see you nodding soon yeah I
don't think so I think it's obviously
it's increasing ten thousand pounds to
fifteen thousand pounds
um I I don't think you've got that
obviously not quite a problem with that
but that's probably in the range of what
we've seen now elsewhere so
it would be and I was thinking of the
question for David would be how how many
assets does that you know effect in
terms of increasing it from 10 15 do you
actually know how many of that that
covers
I think you'd asked me that question
about
two to three years ago I probably would
have said about to enter maybe a bit
less than that but the reason now is
even the small Transit Vans are coming
in over fifteen thousand so they're the
I don't think
none of the even the small Transit bands
there'll be over fifteen thousand so it
really won't affect too many assets at
all
I think we've done a challenge here and
scrutinized that decision
and I feel very comfortable with all the
recommendations you make
and I am happy to propose from the chair
that we
take the recommendations as written
and go to full Council that is and I'll
read it out it's recommended that
members recommend
ous
members recommend that the revised
revisions to The Farmhouse and contract
procedurals to fall Council for approval
that's terrible English I do apologize
going to cross
um yeah so I'm happy to recommend that
from the chair
keeps you happy to Second
um yes I am just just just tidying up
um I'm happy to be very much happy to
vote for the recommendations but on the
the 677 that should be bulk purchases if
that can be tied it up for is that sorry
um I'm really rational it says bulk
purposes I think it should be purchases
oh
purchases yes thank you you can seem a
little praying well yeah and I think
there's just one too many purchase in
the next line down thank you
okay so you're happy to have a second
happy second that
I'll take a vote so all those in favor
unanimous
okay thank you very much indeed
so we will now move on
to review the forward plan on page 43
and having looked at it earlier I don't
think we've got anything
I'll let my I'll let my colors from dap
golf first and that's saying the same
thing yes over March sorry the uh is it
March April I'm sorry the um
meeting 4th of April we will be
proposing winter and audit plan for 20
23 24.
okay fine if if you put that in Karen
thank you
so if we're all happy so David yes you
notice that on this agenda there isn't
um progress with agreed or the actions
uh which I did promise for this meeting
um just time constraints have prevented
me from finishing that piece of work but
I will Faithfully have that on the next
meeting
thank you David
right so with Julie note that
um
item 12 the exclusion the public and I'd
like to move from the chair that the
public be excluded from the remainder of
the meeting because of the likely
disclosure of exempt information by
virtue of paragraph three of part one
and paragraph 10 of part two of schedule
12a of the Local Government Act 1972.
I'll take the vote on that all those in
favor
a second declare